now you probably recognize me from
bridgeton
[Applause]
he stole our hearts and now we'll never
see him again
we found friendship why is the duke gone
for good after rising to fame and having
a multi-thousand dollar contract offer
and handsome
just don't forget that what made paige
declined continuing to play the duke of
hastings
what rumored major role could be even
bigger than a star turn in bridgerton
this is to work you must appear madly in
love
all good things must come to an end and
so must reggae jean paige's time as the
duke of hastings
i have always been yours the recent
announcement came to us in true
bridgeton style
a note from lady whistle down explaining
that we would not see pages the duke in
season 2.
it was quite unexpected news considering
how major a role this was for paige and
all the success and attention the actor
received for it so why would he choose
to leave the bridgerton family so
soon we know he was slated to have a
much smaller role in the next season
was it not big enough to keep him around
the deal he was presented was pretty
good
fifty thousand dollars per episode for
three to five guest episodes is not a
bad deal at all
but it still wasn't enough to keep paige
what we do know is that even though the
duke won't be there we'll still be
seeing phoebe denver in her role as
daphne bridgeton
thank goodness because we're not sure we
could handle losing both of them
i thought you and i were friends with a
great contract offer
a brilliant role and reuniting with
denver on the table
why is paige chosen to move on from
bridgerton it's life-changing it's
incredible
the truth of it is the duke was never
meant to be in the second season to
begin with
that's right when he was first offered
the role on bridgerton the contract was
only for a year
paige explained that his character had a
full story arc and that the part was
only written for the first season
once the producers had seen how
successful the project was and what a
draw page was for the series
they decided it might be worthwhile to
include the duke in season 2.
the team did make their offer but paige
chose to stick with the plan he had
tell me i'm wrong in fact the promise of
a one season story arc was one of the
main appeals for him since he
appreciated the ability to leave the
show
easily after just a season he viewed the
whole project as a kind of limited
series for his role since he's now
prioritizing pursuing a movie career
the way the books are written somewhat
lend themselves to this as well
each of julia quinn's novels focuses on
a different story arc per book
we're so glad to know there was no
animosity behind the choice and have
been so happy to see how positively the
whole team
and paige himself have been since the
announcement in an interview paige said
that he was looking forward to seeing
how the rest of the series went and
watching it conquer the globe
the role was obviously a huge one for
him and in a post on instagram
he called it the ride of a lifetime we
definitely agree with the bridgerton
netflix account who commented that he
would forever be there duke
he is absolutely arduc forever too while
the whole team has been speaking of it
very positively
fans on the other hand aren't so happy
since we were wanting to see
way more of our duke the explosion of
comments online
hasn't been surprising and seems to have
confirmed one thing across the board
everyone is bummed not to see paige as
the duke again
what we can look forward to is his
future screen appearances
[Music]
unsurprisingly paige has been fielding
loads of offers since he swept the
netflix world off its feet and made us
all fall in love with him
we have no doubt his fantastic episode
hosting snl helped boost his popularity
as well
people may associate me with being this
smoldering
sensual luckily we don't have to wait
too long to see him on screen again
since he's currently filming a russo
brothers film for netflix called the
gray man
alongside an all-star cast that includes
chris evans and ryan gosling
it's also been announced that he'll be
featured in a paramount film called
dungeons and dragons coming in spring
2022
if you can't wait that long for more of
the dreamy page check out some of his
other previous projects like sylvie's
love
yeah we're gonna split and the shonda
land series for the people
people call me erica because i walk with
my head
there is one rumor going around that has
us all very excited
and that's the notion that paige could
be
the next james bond when asked about it
in interviews he hasn't
outwardly rejected the idea and seems
pretty delighted by it
so our fingers are crossed because he is
a perfect choice for the bond role
they all want it to happen i want this
to happen
honestly we're rooting for any and all
of his on-screen appearances
we're so glad we got to have the duke
for the time we did
my thoughts of you never end well we
would love to see him in bridgerton
again
we're definitely looking forward to all
of his upcoming projects
fingers crossed will be our next bond
what type of role would you want to see
him do next
you